this week we're talking about cloud run
see cables and managing your cloud I'm
max and welcome to this week in cloud
where we serve you the lowest latency
news first up a minor update cloud run
is generally available cloud run is a
fully managed service execution
environment that lets you run stateless
containers without worrying about
infrastructure we're pretty obsessed
with it over here and we hope you like
it too let's check out this little
product it might just make your day once
you've fallen in love with cloud run you
may find yourself with multiple cloud
solutions that's okay it turns out from
many enterprise networks it's
complicated
most businesses end up a multi cloud or
hybrid cloud and on-premise the network
intelligence center was designed to
simplify things for your network
operations team by providing
comprehensive visibility into your
entire cloud strategy as you scale that
cloud strategy it's important to us that
you were only ever charged for what you
use and that you're using exactly what
you need to help the budget API has also
been released to beta the budget API is
designed for managing budgets
programmatically at scale which is
critical when you have multiple budgets
across an organization try it out and
let us know what you think subsea cables
are literally changing the world by
using a data pipe to bring continents
closer together metaphorically speaking
of course the Kure cable is ten thousand
five hundred kilometres long and runs
from the u.s. to Chile and now that it's
operational we're starting on the first
branch to Panama no matter where your
users are Google Cloud is here to help
you reach them if you want to read more
about these announcements or see a full
list check out the link have any
thoughts or ideas leave us a comment or
tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you